Okay,
should be live here.
Hello folks. So I just have to set the
set the stream category.
Is GitHub still down?
And I get um
He just Hang on. Let me read what he Let
me read what Finn wrote.
I want to make sure I actually
understand the state of everything. This
is all that's missing from Net Hack 646.
Okay.
Wait, he didn't change the config.
Change the encoder.
All right, let me see what he has done.
Okay, some OBS fixes.
Embeddings for rolls.
One hot should be equal to what?
Embedding.
I'm going to be working on some of
Finn's net hack stuff.
General net hack stuff. Rangers throw
arrows instead of Sue shooting them
Okay, so he's ablating off search.
Oh, there's Finn. Contribute to pro.
It's all open source. Most new people
start by like making an env or
something. That's typically the easiest
way to get a feel for it and then they
move on to fancier stuff from there.
Yes, 5.0 is the current and release
branch.
So, Finn, the first thing I'm seeing
with this search 20
is uh x-axis here should be wall clock.
The point of not using search more than
anything is that it's very slow.
Wall clock lower down. Okay, I'm getting
to that running. So, the run command I
could go either way on it. It's not
super inefficient a lot of the time.
Correcting discounting is also fine.
Well, actually, is it? Let me think
about that.
No, it's not.
Actually, kind of tough to say,
honestly.
And it is expected that it takes a few
more steps to solve without search
without a search 20, but it should still
be faster.
I actually I would argue you could even
potentially give it like S3 or
something,
content for free. The whole library is
free and open source.
Oh, wait. Here's the
green line matches wall clock.
Wait, the green one was discounting it.
Oh, but it stops doing it if you
discount it,
so it's faster.
So, yeah, basically. And wait, where's
the one with uh with orange?
No,
the best line is N.
Wait,
it's green.
Not used as soon as you discount it. I
don't know whether it's proper or not to
be honest, Finn, but it's definitely
it's definitely using it too much.
Arguably discounting it should be the
correct thing. It's kind of it's kind of
difficult to say,
but clearly it was
it was overusing it
on the scale to longer runs. That's
probably just learning rate or
something, man. Though I wouldn't worry
too much about that.
Where's my um where's the chart again?
Do you have the chart of the PF uh by
rolls on the latest thing?
Like do you have like this chart for the
latest the latest PR?
Oh wait. Uh yo Finn, this is bad, isn't
it? Look at this. I didn't realize this
has good score. Very good score. But
look at the depth. Is this a score
config?
Yeah, I I bet. Do you have multi-roll
depth?
Cuz like I've been saying, the score
thing is kind of troll.
trained one.
Oh, we definitely need that.
Do you have um the previous one carried
over? Do you have the depth config from
previous so I can try it?
What am I working on? Currently, we're
pulling in some of Finn's work on Net
Hack and seeing if we can push it a
little bit.
I just moved over and score training
tanked.
Uh, no. I think did we repro?
Oh, yeah. That did tank.
I don't think we retrained with your
embedding stuff.
I did pull in the embedding stuff, but
I'm confused, Finn, because one hot is
the same as embedding.
Like the way that an embedding works is
it's just a lookup.
And the way that a one hot works because
it's one hot is you get one row lookup
and everything else is zero.
Like that's literally how you can
implement an embedding.
We definitely want to get Net Hack onto
this
after broken internet.
The whole internet's been broken today.
Well,
mine was earlier
with some really weird stuff. I think it
might have just been GitHub, though.
There was some sort of GitHub
screwiness, right?
Looking forward to the net hack runs.
Yeah, it's going to be fun.
So Finn, I had some ideas for you.
I'd kind of just like to chat about some
of the net hack stuff whenever you're
available.
I'm happy to do that on stream or off
stream if you're more comfortable with
that.
I have a few ideas for things that we
could do to figure out like what the
agent isn't isn't doing correctly.
Join VC now. Sure. And let me know if
you'd feel more comfortable doing that
off stream. That's fine by me.
If not though, I'll uh I'll just hop in
the the VC.
Hope that works.
Hey Finn, how's it going?
Good. You chill doing this on stream?
Okay.
Oh, yeah. No, no, no. Just like you
listen to me here. I It's just I keep
stream running. Um, cool. Yeah. Yeah.
Echo's gone. Cool. So, I think basically
we need to figure out what the agent can
and cannot use. Um, we need like to
actually get an assessment of like
specifically where it's failing.
And I had an idea based on some of my
earlier work like on neural MMO that
might work. So, what if we just built,
and I think this is so simple, you could
literally just lm this crap. But, uh,
what if we just built like a test level
that's not actually in Net Hack, right?
But just like a standalone test level.
You just make like a a basic room and
stuff. Um the actual actions and stuff
don't need to work, but basically just
have the agent walk into a room uh that
has like some item or has something on
the ground and we can basically change
what is there and we can see whether the
activations or actions change
significantly in response to different
items and things being available.
Yeah, to be fair, we could also just
very easily set do we don't have state
sets with net hack, do we?
Somebody was working on that at some
point. That see that sounds hard. I
think there was an old thing in the
Discord where somebody had that. Um,
if the state's in one strct and there's
nothing else, you can literally just
like mems set the strct, can't you?
Okay, cuz that would be another thing.
Then we wouldn't have to build a
standalone. You could basically just
like walk around in a level and like
give yourself some stuff,
right? And set up a scenario.
Yeah. Yeah. I've seen mini hack, but
it's
it
isn't mini hack like super slow.
Yeah, I wouldn't want to train on that.
We just need to get a matched eval cuz
I'm just trying to think like, you know,
if it sees uh a wand of digging and it
just doesn't care, right?
or if it can see if if it sees food
ration, does it care a lot? It should.
Um, I think we could probably figure out
cuz like stuff like, oh, it can it can
shoot it can throw the arrows. It can't
shoot them. Like this should be
instantly solved in my mind. No.
Yeah. So, I honestly think it's just
obs, right? It's like the agent can't
actually see correctly,
but we need a way of figuring that out
in a sort of automated way cuz I mean,
it is pretty effective to just watch the
agent play the game a bunch, but we
would ideally have something more
directed.
I I think at least for this it would
make sense. Now, there's some higher
level stuff that I honestly don't know
what we're going to do cuz I tried a few
times off stream the agents just to rush
like just rush down strategy. It doesn't
work.
Like you just need to get very lucky if
you're not going to actually take the
time to go and like, you know, there are
strategies that are almost mandatory.
Like you kind of need to do a little bit
of price ID at the very least. You need
to have an identify scroll, right? You
need to be able to identify stuff.
Should we not hear the other in
conversation?
I thought I fixed that. Say something,
Finn.
>> Oh, my bad. I I unmuted the wrong
channel.
>> Should we not hear the other in
conversation?
>> You got to tell me when I messed
something up. All right.
>> Um
>> Oh, my bad. I I unmuted the wrong
channel. Thanks for that, guys.
>> So, anyways,
>> something. multiroll is very good.
>> Okay. So anyways,
>> I think multi roll is very good.
>> Oh,
to not attack. Isn't that just conduct?
>> Yeah, you're just screwed. Oh,
How to win with healer net hack.
>> Quarter staff.
>> Healer artifact.
>> Training quarter staffs.
Claim the staff. Quarter staff. Quest
artifact. Drain resistance and passive
healing. Training quarter staffs.
Claim the staff
grants drain resistance and passive
healing.
interesting.
>> That's
there's just a lot of stuff that you
have to do. I don't know. I I watch a
fair number of net hack runs. Um
>> there's just a lot of stuff that you
have to do.
>> Typically people that are trying to win,
they just they take their early game
very slow and they really squeeze quite
a lot of typically people that are
trying to take their early game very
slow want to know at least what identify
scroll is.
>> They'll really like price ID stuff. Some
people want to know what the identify
scroll is
>> so that they can bless everything and
then
>> some people will just make a bunch of
holy water. I see that pretty often. So
that they can bless everything and then
they can have blessed identification.
>> Right.
>> I hear you. How the heck do you hear me?
Okay, hang on.
Okay, hang on guys.
How about this? Does this work?
professional researcher. All right. Not
a professional streamer. The streaming
is for fun. Are we good?
Let me check Twitch
this
Well, now wait. Now I'm going to hear
myself three times if I have the stream
on.
Wait, we are good now. Voice is
different, but we're good.
I don't understand how it's possible
that they can't hear you.
isn't an option to only record Discord.
Okay, this one is me. This is the one
that's me that's not janky, right?
You can keep it as a separate channel.
I don't see how you add a channel to OBS
for an application.
Can you do that?
You can say whatever, Finn. It's I have
it like temporarily.
Hang on. Can you add Oh, wait. You can
add application audio capture. It's in
beta.
Uh, okay.
Window is Discord
>> testing.
Hello. Does this work, guys?
>> Hello world. We are hopefully back.
>> You should be able to hear us both now.
That was good advice. Yeah. Yeah. I
didn't realize you could add It actually
says beta, so I that you can add like an
audio capture for just an application.
Thanks, Jess.
>> So, we are we good now?
>> Yeah. Yeah, we should be good.
>> Amazing. Very good.
>> Okay. I also have uh while we're
talking, I have this thing retraining on
the box. Um, by the way, I it's probably
the degradation. My guess is that there
uh there was a change with the way we do
advantage advantage and there was also
more importantly the async thing. So
>> yeah, it looked like a like a norm got
removed, was it?
>> Yes, I removed the norm on advantage.
>> Yeah. So that probably just wants a
reweep should be fine. God damn it.
Okay.
managed to get my finger stuck in the
the plastic cup. Whatever. Um,
I'm trying to think what we should do
with this next. So, multiroll is good.
We definitely want depth sweeps on with
like the latest thing on on multi- roll.
Yeah,
>> score went up. So, presumably depth will
also go up once we're actually
optimizing for it.
>> Yeah, I I think depth will benefit more
as well because pickaxes are are a lot
more common for like archaeologists and
some of the other roles.
>> I would be very curious to see whether
this means that if you get the agent to
nomish mines and it gets a pickaxe if it
will just start digging down.
>> Yeah. Well, like archaeologist already
does that for score. So, like
>> Right. Right. But if the other ones get
the pickaxe, will they then know to dig
down since archaeologist knows to dig
down?
>> Yeah,
>> I I I'm pretty sure I've seen the other
roles as well using the pickaxes.
>> Good.
Okay, good. Um,
some of the roles being awful is just
expected. Like,
>> yeah. Yeah,
>> I don't know. I should probably just
play some games on healer and see what
happens.
I think I could probably get deeper than
five, but
>> yeah, probably. I think it's just like
kiting and using your pet and things
like this. I think it also throws knives
as well or something like that.
>> Scalpel that's apparently pretty
worthless.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, and for the the chat, this is this
is Finn who's working on Net Hack. He's
interning with us this summer. He also
built the drone env. And uh we're
essentially just trying to figure out
integration for net hack and then what
other experiments we can do to push it
even more.
>> Yeah.
>> Trying to figure out I definitely think
we need some sort of like
is that what people call mechinp? If it
is, sure, but just some sort of like
viz, some sort of ability to test
specific sensitivity to items and things
>> because things like the bow is like
that's ridiculous, right? That it can't
see something that basic. Do you know
what it was? Is it like
>> is it like one specific item encoding or
something like what was the thing that
you added that made that learn
instantly?
It was I don't know which of the three
of these it was, but it was like a bit
for you have a bow that you haven't
wielded and then like a bit for you like
the bow you're wielding has correct ammo
like in your inventory. And then there
was a third one that I can't remember,
but it it was just like three flags for
just like you have a bow and then you
have ammo.
>> See, that leads me to suspect that the
encoding that you have for items is
really hard for them to learn or
something, right? because it should just
be able to see like bow, arrow,
whatever.
>> It's really easy cuz it's your starting
item, right? It's not like, oh, you have
to randomly get a bow and randomly get
arrows and randomly equip both. Like,
you start with it,
right?
>> Yeah. It's probably the entity encoder
just like compressing everything down a
bit.
>> Have you tried to like see if that works
if you just trained ranger?
>> I haven't done ranger only. I've tried
pretty much every like combination of
increasing model dims that you could
think of and none of them seem to help
that much. They're all
>> be useful if I just sanity checked your
encoding structure.
>> Yeah, that would be good. I mean the
whole like cuda is is vibe cuda but
>> yeah that's why I'm a little sketched
about looking at that code. Would you
like to either explain or diagram or
whatever the encoder structure at the
very least? What? At least like let's
diagram if you like what you think it is
and then we can also if it looks sane
then I guess we can try to debug it.
>> Yeah, let me grab um
>> I got Claude to make a pretty nice
little visual the other day. Let me grab
that.
>> Also, did did it help did it actually
help telling the agent its role? We have
that question in the chat. I would
expect that it should just know
immediately its role based on its
starting inventory.
Um, I never actually tried not having
the one hop. Um,
>> I'd be shocked if it doesn't just like
learn instantly cuz it's inventory.
>> I guess it could help if it like forgets
somehow later on, but yeah.
>> Yeah, it feels like a free win just
having the one hot, but yeah, it might
be worth testing.
>> Let's see if it does anything.
I mean, I'm going to be ablating even
like the neural MMO 3 net now that we
have the major bug fixed to just delete
all the biases and delete all the other
crap that we have in there.
>> Yeah, I'd be interested to see how like
the like if the AR architecture I'm
using for this transfers. It does it
does seem to work quite well.
>> Entity encoder architectures generally
work. It's just very obnoxious to make
them fast.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like the the 16 dim
bottleneck into 128 max is pretty is
pretty great for that.
That was a good point.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I really like that
architecture that was we have that on
the website now for the minimal like the
little minimal anvil.
>> Even a problem as simple as this minimal
one. I have it on the stream now. This
does not solve without an entity
encoder.
>> Okay. I've sent you I've sent you
Claude's
look at the the architecture which is
correct.
>> Is this private?
>> Uh no.
blog can help, but finding this page is
not one of Does that link resolve for
you?
>> Oh, I may need to h Yeah, I'll need to
give it to anyone with the link. Here we
go. Copy.
>> Did you leave?
>> Second one should work.
>> Uh, we are training we're training on
net hack now. We train lots of different
models for question chat.
>> Does that second
>> I didn't say they were limited. I said
that they were narrow.
>> Yes, this works.
>> Perfect.
>> What on earth is this?
>> It's basically just like a lot of entity
encoders and then
>> it's like clawed vibe coding a mini
website.
>> Yeah, I think it's fun. I quite like the
quite like the
>> Do I want to click this button?
Is this act is this just HTML or is this
some absolute disaster? I wonder.
>> Let me see what you got. Oh jeez.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> mute the stream though.
>> All right.
>> Yeah, I've muted it.
>> Okay. So,
>> yeah, I never learned there for a
reason. This is
>> auto ascend mean. This is their mean
over classes.
>> No. So, that is um that's 7,000 mean is
is ours. Yeah. Auto ascend mean is
3,800. Their median though is like 5,300
and ours is what? 45,500.
>> Okay.
>> So, we we absolutely smashed the mean,
but not we're not quite there on the
median yet.
>> Okay.
When did you get is 330k with async?
>> Uh, yes, that will have been with Async.
I've done I've done everything with
async in the last
>> Oh, very good.
>> week or so.
>> Very good. Yeah, async is good. There is
a little bit of a degradation, but in
all of my tests, uh, I've gotten soda
with it, so it's worth it's worth using.
>> Yeah, it it's it's done its job so far
for me as well.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. So, those check that we're
actually parsing in 16 correctly.
in. What do you mean by that?
>> I see map glyphs 21 by 79 are in int 16.
>> Uh well, I haven't I haven't checked
that.
>> Well, cuz I never added in6 support to
anything. So, I don't know if I merged
it without noticing,
>> but I'm hoping that it's actually seeing
correctly because that would explain a
lot.
>> Yeah, I'll I'll check that. I I would be
surprised if you get as good results as
you have without being able to see like
something that important, but you never
know. Are all pretty OP.
>> 27 BL stats, 20 77 extras, 55 inventory
glyphs, 55 X8 item state, and then
>> so those
those are 55, but they're pointer nets.
So it's like maximum 55. Otherwise, it's
just like a a no op for any empty slots.
>> So, local crop
9 by9 egocentric and that does
something.
>> Yeah, that that seemed to help a lot.
>> Okay. I am not I'm not surprised that
that helps. Um
Wait, you have like a weird Do you have
like a non-over overlapping patch
encoder?
Yeah, that's it.
It's a conf.
Well, it Yeah. So each patch is like
it's equivalent to like one conf like
kernel I guess.
>> But is it separate per
>> but yeah there's no it's like a comp but
there's no overlap between
>> that's so funny. I was just thinking
that was literally like a type of layer
that was used in some of the first
comnet architectures ever before it was
dropped because images you want it to be
shared. Yeah. Yeah. You found out the
thing here where like the actual where
it is in the image matters meaning that
the con prior that the thing that the
con gives you about locality is not
perfect.
Um
>> yeah so the the important point as well
is the the global patches have like dx
and dy from the player as well. So that
that helps.
>> Okay. There's probably some ablation we
can do there but cool.
Yeah.
>> Do you know how fast the net is, by the
way, with the like relative to the
envoder,
but that was this was like several weeks
ago.
>> Okay. I'm just wondering if we can like
if we can optimize the net and then just
crank it even faster
>> cuz with Async now you can get 2x sample
reuse if your net's faster, right?
>> Yeah, the M is definitely a bit slow.
But it's not it's not like
>> but with async it's no longer it's no
longer the case that it's not worth
making your net faster,
>> right? Because the env is slower because
you can still crank more reuse on your
data.
Yeah, I'll see if I can I'll see if I
can make it faster then.
>> Oh, yeah.
It's a useful little thing to look at at
least. Okay. Inventory
status.
You get the character triagrams.
Wait, that are hashed into buckets.
>> Yeah, those are those are funny.
That's sketchy as
>> I remember when I when I implemented
that I got like plus a thousand score
just like immediately and I was like
wait that is like unbelievable for how
simple it is but the yeah the message
encoding kind of just worked. That's
weird
which is completely ridiculous.
Bill embedding eight slots with level
fail percent and return
16 per slot.
Why is roll 13 by 16?
>> Uh where are you looking?
>> Race is 5 * 8 identity.
>> Ah so that is
>> oh x16 bits. Wait. Huh? No,
>> this might be before I changed it to
embedding. And that's like the one hot.
>> Okay.
Zoom in a little bit.
>> Not sure why it's 13.
>> But yeah, it's just like a I don't know.
I think it's a 16 dim and like embed for
the the roll and then eight for race and
gender and alignment.
I guess that's one for each roll. But
yeah, that makes sense.
But like you only use one
>> 13 queries.
Oh yeah. Did we we didn't really talk
about the way that you were doing the
action decoding, did we?
>> Uh I don't think so yet. Yeah. Like
>> you had a lot of heads.
>> Yeah, that that that is that is one of
the things at the moment. So like you
can get the benefit the most of the
benefits of the conditional action tree
stuff just by like I guess unrolling the
tree like you just instead of having
this this nested structure you just have
everything out flat and you just pick
the heads you want
>> and that way it is it is conditioned
exactly how you'd want but you get less
parameter sharing I guess
I think there is a there is an edge case
where like if you need slot and
direction that isn't conditioned
properly as I have it set up now.
>> Mhm.
>> Um
but yeah, that's that's another thing to
look at.
See, so let me answer it. So CV for
actions you do RL that's a different
objective entirely. That's the whole
point. Um
and number of parameters is this 3x 512
plus the encoder like couple mil
parameters or something.
It's somewhere between a few hundred
thousand and a couple million
This is a lot of glyphs.
Yeah, it is. It is a lot.
And that that's not helped by the like
the randomized names either.
>> No. Well,
and it's annoying because technically
the randomized names even matter because
you need to be able to know like, oh,
it's the same one.
>> Yeah. So, for for like when the engine
doesn't give you the explicit ID when
you I don't know,
>> engrave a wand, then yeah, you kind of
just need to remember or you I guess you
could you could just have some rule that
IDs it for you.
Um,
>> but it was funny because even when you
you gave it the true glyphs, it didn't
get much better.
>> Yeah, that that was weird. That was
surprising
>> cuz I think that if you give me a build
where you everything is IDed, the game
becomes way easier,
>> right?
>> Yeah. I'd be interested to see if that
changes with like the multiroll stuff
now that it's seeing more items. But
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah, that was definitely weird.
I mean, even knowing just beatitude.
Well, admittedly, you get beatitude for
free as long as you don't ditch your
pet.
Yeah, I guess the main thing you'd want
to ID early game are scrolls. And it
doesn't really use scrolls that much,
assuming it's not getting beatitude from
anywhere else. You need beatitude,
though.
I'm trying to think what we do about all
of these glyphs. Like,
I mean, you only see a subset of them in
the early game at least. That's like I
guess the the saving grace in some ways.
Well, I know for sure that the encoding
is going to be slow if we ever need to
optimize that more. But
people have used the weird like pixel
encoder before. That seems kind of
janky.
And then wait, how are you conving?
You're embedding each of these. So you
have like width by height by 32 and then
you have con over that
>> for what part of the network?
the like the initial encoding for like
the map.
>> It's equivalent to just a flatten and
then MLP just flatten into linear.
>> Wait, is that
>> Well,
>> this doesn't look like it. This AD
patches thing looks different.
>> I guess each patch is a flatten into a
linear and that's like one com like
kernel I guess.
because that that is exactly what it
computes if I if I understand.
>> Oh, that's really weird. Hang on.
>> It's just like a really like sparse
comp.
Well, it's not a con first of all
because it's it miss it's missing the
fundamental thing of a con which is
shared weights
>> formulation that enables planning.
>> Yes.
>> Uh CV it's policy gradients. You should
check my like my intro guide to RL for
that on X.
>> But reinforcement learning this is this
is the mechanism by which you take
actions observe rewards and get a
gradient from that.
Uh very close to Q-learning. Yes, very
close to Q-learning.
>> Related but distinct. Ours is on policy
but close enough.
Patches and a vision transformer. Yeah,
they're nonover overlapping though and
it's weird.
>> I did try a big just like a big con a
while ago and it it didn't seem to help.
But again, this is
>> No, no, no. I don't I don't think it
should necessarily be shared either. I'm
trying to figure out what the correct
thing is, though.
>> I see.
>> If I were going to mess with the
architecture,
right?
Okay, if I were going to mess with the
architecture and try something out,
I would probably do like a very short
like small channel comp just for the
level architecture.
>> So without all the fancy glyph
embeddings
just like to get the structure of the
map and stuff.
>> And I probably would have like a
>> kind of like the snakeet. I'd have a
very small shared conf and then quickly
flatten it into the global features
and then I would probably do the entity
encoder to all the items and mobs or
whatever on the level.
That's probably what I would do.
>> So like including positions.
>> Yeah. So I'd basically separate out the
map layer. Actually, I wonder if you
just do terrain like that terrain
feature command, how many glyphs can
there be?
What do you mean for for terrain?
>> Mhm. Isn't there a command that just
shows the terrain?
>> It's just like like pound terrain,
right?
Is this like in the net hack game?
Yeah. Yeah. It's a net hack. You never
used that?
>> Nope.
All right.
Do I have it on here?
Is this the right Wait, what's packages
net hack
and not install some?
Wait, are there different glyphs for all
of the different types of wall as well?
Surely not.
>> That's what I was wondering.
>> Like the tile map. That's funny.
No way. There's 96 according to Claude
and it's got access to the engine.
Okay. So, if I if I just walk around in
here a little bit, right?
The terrain can command known map
without monsters, objects, and traps.
It does still show you a bunch of stuff.
It has doors and fountains and things.
Presumably, we could prune it
and just get like a pretty small set
>> just for terrain and then entity and
code. the mobs and stuff.
I wonder if that's better.
Yeah, that could work.
I think
I mean I would have a feeling that with
the global I guess you do have dxdy with
everything which is pretty close I'd say
to correct.
I'm trying to think how we can test this
squash.
>> There's a lot to squash,
>> you know. Actually, Finn, we can test
all of this stuff without having to even
retrain. Like
you I think that this is kind of the
time where it seems to me like this type
of stuff, it probably things aren't it's
not super clear like where exactly
things are breaking and why and like
what you can like specifically do to fix
stuff.
Um,
that's my impression at least. Do you
feel like you know like, oh no, I know
exactly what to try next, next, next
next to fix all the problems?
>> No, it's not it's not super clear at
all. I mean, there are there are maybe
like two things that it's like you can
sort of mine the variance between high
performing runs to get like more
consistent runs, but there's nothing
clearly to
>> bring the ceiling up. So in that case,
let me make some suggestions because I
think that the main thing is figuring
out what the agent is and is not
doing.
And the best thing I can think of for
that is like we can basically set up
some scenarios
uh either with the mini hack or just if
you have some level of control over net
hack just with net hack directly
like can we just get a level right with
the agent in it run it for a few steps
so the RNN state is reasonable and then
if you just like spawn a specific enemy
far away does it change what it's doing
does it change its action logs at all
Um, if you spawn an item a couple rooms
over, does it notice? Like,
there are lots of things we can do
essentially to test whether it's
actually reacting correctly.
And then we can do it to both longtail
things where like it probably hasn't
seen very many vampire lords, but maybe
it doesn't know that that's a bad thing.
Maybe it doesn't even know it's an
enemy.
But then if it sees I don't know what's
like a common dangerous enemy early on
a couple of ants maybe a couple a couple
of ants.
>> Yeah.
>> If you spawn that like a room over
>> it should like that should dramatically
change the value function. That should
change a lot of stuff. Right. And if it
doesn't
is it cuz it can't see you know if we
put it in that 9 by9 window does it
suddenly change? If we put it like one
tile outside the 9 by9, does it suddenly
like drop off?
>> Yeah, that's a good idea.
>> I'm just trying to think how we can get
you like a tight dev loop again where
you can actually test this stuff cuz
without that, I understand like research
projects kind of they just tend to drag
and start feeling pretty awful cuz it's
not clear how to make progress.
>> Yeah, it it does take a long time at the
moment.
>> I've done that for years, my guy. This
is why I'm trying to avoid this.
>> And uh basically you you do this by
finding ways that you can make progress
that are like pretty straightforward and
have a tight loop on them.
Yeah. I think in this case like the
mechan stuff would actually I think that
would work
because I like my main fear when I see
custom encodings like this like you
obviously need custom encoders but most
of the errors are
okay they're reward space errors are
pretty common but most of the errors
otherwise are because the model can't
see something clearly
to give you an idea right the neural MMO
bug we've just fixed. Now, we just got
soda with 1/ 1,000th of the data after
that fix.
>> Yeah, that that's that's crazy.
>> And I kind of suspected that there was a
bug. It's just funny. The end is still
not solved yet, by the way. Not even
close. Um, but we did get soda with a
tiny amount of data. So, I think that we
should kind of rule out all instances of
like the model can't see something that
it very obviously should be able to see.
Yeah, I agree. That sounds like a good
idea.
>> Yeah. Um,
how hard is it to like add stuff into
like a existing Net Hack game? Like, is
the structure of the game simple enough
that you could just get Claude or or
Grock to like wire up like a thing to
just edit mobs into the game or
whatever? Edit things into the game at
different spots.
>> Yeah, I don't think that should be too
bad. And if that is bad, then Minihack
does it somehow. So we can we can look
at what they do.
>> Okay. Then that that would be my
recommendation. I would say would be the
next stage for this like the next thing
for you to if you want to make this
thing way better is going to be to see
what it can and cannot see. Um I think
you want to ablate all the different
things in the encoder and in the decoder
based on that, not just randomly, not
having to do a new training run every
single time.
We definitely want to start with a good
depth config where you've watched a few
games with the policy though and you see
it's mostly doing reasonable stuff.
Um,
so I would definitely want to have that.
I think you can ablate from there based
on those scenarios. And then there
should also you should have a simplicity
bias. So, you know, the goal should be
to have the simplest or fastest way of
encoding that matches Perf and that, you
know, fixes those scenarios.
>> Yeah.
How do you identify what it can and
cannot see without a bunch of training
runs? So, Jess, if you take the agent in
a scenario and you drop a monster next
to it, does it massively just shift its
action props? Does it shift the value
function? Does it react at all?
State sets might be very useful there,
Finn. So you can see what it does with
and without. To be fair, um, if it's
already if all the data is already in
one big strruct, that's literally one
mem copy.
I think you can probably get a lot of
that stuff uh validated automatically as
well.
The means. Oops.
What?
A I was hoping we would get genie.
>> Oops.
>> Yeah, it would be it would be
interesting to see if you can like
recover the location of the entrance and
exit
>> from the the hidden state or something
like that
>> because it's not obvious that it it
knows where it is at all times. Like
sometimes it does just kind of wander
around. Whether that be because it
doesn't know where it is or because it
it just wants to wander for a bit. I
don't know.
>> Mhm.
Just checking on whether this depth run
is done.
I'd like to look at that fast package as
well. Fast. Was it fast NLA? Do you have
the link?
>> Uh, yeah. So, this is just like my vibe
port.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh, let me grab it. Well,
>> it's not even a port. It's just like
your optimizations on the original,
right?
>> Yeah. It's very mild. So mostly it's
like bin the Python, fix a ridiculous
number of bugs in in just like the
environment and then go from there. Let
me DM this to you.
>> Mhm.
Just want to see how close this is to uh
is this just like C99 with a bunch of
like what's the build setup for this? So
we have
Python lib Z
does this what what does Net Hack itself
does this thing have dependencies
um let me have a look I don't I I kind
of doubt it
nothing heavy
>> there's still Python here but presumably
>> I'm just wondering if it is just C99
like
>> we can build it for the web and then we
can put it on the website which would be
pretty awesome.
Oh yeah, we can we can definitely find a
way to do that.
>> I mean, that would be really sweet,
right?
>> I would be wounded if we couldn't get it
on the website.
>> I will I will code is it? It's not It
shouldn't The binary shouldn't be that
big, right?
>> I mean, it's a it's a lot of lines of
code. I think it's several hundred
thousand, but
a
>> couple megs though, like
>> Yeah, it's not it's not like ridiculous.
It should be fine.
What's happening? Is the tra Did the
training run not work?
>> Yeah, it did very poorly.
>> Yeah, that that'll be the the same with
score then. It'll just be some mismatch
between like the new 5 and the 5C.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Stuff.
>> Get it on a different page.
>> Oh, it won't slow the main page
regardless. It only loads it when you
click it.
Yeah, I'll I'll have to rewe probably if
if there's a couple of things that have
changed.
Yeah, that is not that is not good.
That's
>> Yeah, you can get that thing rewept.
I'll have it merge.
>> What was the pryo?
>> What was the pryo in the config? I
wonder.
>> Uh oh, that's another big one. We
deleted pryo, man.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm thinking. Cuz like
if it was using it heavily, then
>> actually, let me see.
I don't see pryo at all in here. It was
on default potentially.
But then Horizon,
where's your Horizon? 128. So pryo. The
reason we could get rid of pryo is it
basically does nothing for long horizon
and uh all of the sweeps tend towards
long horizon. Now
>> were they getting like 512? because I
saw the the limit is still 512.
>> Typically it doesn't go that high.
Typically we see 128 or 256.
>> Yeah. Okay, that makes sense
cuz the the more recent sweeps have been
tending towards well for net hack 512
and then the gamma like 0.999
like seven or something like super super
long horizon
for it's a little odd for net hack for
gamma to be that high but not too too
crazy I suppose.
Yeah, this is like mid sweep. But
>> I don't fully understand the advantage
norm stuff yet. By the way, um my
thinking on that is essentially just
Muan is absorbing it though,
>> right?
>> Because it was computing advantage and
then scaling it by mini batch anyways,
which is bad. There probably is some
sort of advantage norm thing to
compensate for the squared loss like
magnitudes, but um I think that the
miniorm thing was not helping. And
actually, we got soda on mazes without
it,
>> right? Oh, that's good.
We've actually sewed all the like all
the big ends at this point.
And we have 60 M's now.
>> Yeah, the website's looking looking big
now.
>> Yeah, all these ones. Like
>> some of these are very promising in my
mind as well.
The only one thing on the website that I
noticed a long, it might have even been
Sam that noticed this, but the GIF of
the puffer has like a slightly different
background to the
>> It does. And I've never been able to
reexport it either cuz it was like super
old. So, we have a new puffer modeled,
>> but the thing is it's just slightly off
and it looks good in some ways, but it
doesn't quite have the charm of the
original and I haven't been able to fix
it.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> And like we didn't even try to like make
the puffer look different. We didn't
want to replace the puffer. We just
wanted to get it remodeled to like and
slightly streamlined uh so that we could
add new animations to it,
but in the process like something
slightly off. And it's just one of those
really subtle art things where it's like
you change one polygon and oh now it
looks right. But yeah.
>> Yeah.
Is drone is the drone like frame
>> Yeah. Is drone is the drone like frame rate working now?
rate working now?
>> Uh I have it on my stream. You can tell
me.
>> Yeah, when I change when I press tab it
breaks it. So apparently I broke one
thing or another.
>> Yeah, that that should be changing the
task.
>> So there's there's basically just a long
tail of of things to fix with all the
ends. Um I'm hopefully going to have my
community just like tell me all the
things broken.
>> Yeah, I mean I can I can fix drone as
well.
>> I'm sure that I broke just with
integration.
Yeah,
>> drone's cool though.
I had to like change stuff to have the
single demo and lots of things.
Battle is not logging perf. Oops.
This is another end that I made a while
ago.
I didn't quite finish it as you can
tell.
It has like ground to ground, ground to
air, air to ground. It has a lot of
different things.
Okay. Um,
anything else to address with net hack
fin like Oh, let me read this real quick
to see if there's anything in your train
log. Nothing in PR.
Just reweep it looks like.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Just a reap.
>> I'll see if I can get a stable one.
>> Yeah. I'll I'll push everything in this
and then we can reweep it.
>> Sounds good.
>> Yeah. I think that's I think that's
everything.
>> Yeah. I I would just try to get yourself
that nice tight loop on um on
interpretability and then like all the
stuff where it's like even if you're
playing and you'd say like, man, you
know, I typically do this. It's like,
huh, I wonder if the agent does this.
Like you should be able to test that
very quickly. Like, oh, I wonder what
the agent does with fountains. I don't
know. Let's put a fountain there.
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> If you can't actually get the thing to
interact with stuff, you can cheat it
into the observations. Though, it would
be much better if you can actually just
get it into the game.
>> Yeah. Gives
>> you more testing opportunities.
That's strategy.
>> Okay, I think that's basically the best
advice I can give you for now. I mean,
the net hack looks awesome. I really do
want to have um some depth sweeps as
default, though, because
the score stuff is very impressive
versus auto ascend, but in my mind, like
just getting through more of the game is
the the really important benchmark. Um
>> that's not farmable.
>> Completely agree. I completely
completely agree. The the only thing
that makes score like sticky I guess is
that it is it is a good test of how
resourceful the policy is like every
time
>> like early even up to like a week ago
when I was giving it like a new trying
to get it to do something new like you
could immediately see in score like okay
like it's it's learned something here
whereas with depth it would it would
maybe just like rush down and not care
about this new thing. But yeah, I I
completely agree with
>> it's very possible that the depth config
is too myopic. Um, my hope with depth
config was like you're only going to be
able to get so far down by rushing and
then you're going to have to learn to
taper and like slow down for some stuff.
So,
yeah, I I do see what you mean though. I
see what you mean.
>> Yeah, we'll get there eventually for
sure. Presumably though there is still
going to be some overlap like if it's
just not using wands correctly or if
it's not using jewelry or uh if doesn't
know beatitudes um like presumably there
should be some stuff that's improvable
with depth though I could see yeah being
much sparer and like small things you
can't really track as well. Yeah, that's
that's the only difficulty
you can those
>> like the fixes.
>> Okay, I will I will push this stuff. Um,
so this will be ready for sweep.
Hopefully I haven't giga broken
anything.
Um, and
2:00 p.m. I will have some client stuff
most likely later this week to deal
with. I think I'm probably rest of today
just going to go through some of the
more promising ends and see how much
work it is to fix up various ones. Like
some of these Ms are just really cool to
me. Like this boss fight end.
This was just a super basic end that
Insta solves that somebody submitted,
but I could totally see a very like nice
expansion of this to lots of different
mechanics. This aphine lock from Kinvert
apparently is a pretty good test. We
have this ants env here that like never
got dealt with. That one's pretty cool.
We do end pendulum.
>> Yeah, bring back five pendulums.
>> Yeah, craft deck and crafter. Obviously,
these need fixing, but we already have
somebody doing this. Did you see this
fish sim? Well, there'll be a blog post
on this later in the week, but this is a
support of a fish. Yeah, this is a fish
sim.
>> These are fish getting food.
Yeah, that that looked really cool.
>> Yeah, this is actually like a port of a
different paper to puffer and it's way
faster.
>> How should we normalize score for perf?
You perf. You're trying to put it
between zero and one. Score can be
whatever.
>> Okay.
>> Right. I'm going to head out now,
Joseph.
>> Thank you, Finn.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> Yep.
>> I think we've got we've got some stuff
to work on. Absolutely. Yeah. And let me
know if you get stuck anywhere. See if I
can help. All right.
>> And use the boxes. Like, don't worry
about the box. If you run out of
credits, just let me know. I'll put
more.
>> Yeah, we'll do.
>> All right. Cool. Speak to you soon.
>> Yep.
>> See you.
>> That was fun.
aware of the 0ero to one
usually. Okay, first of all, let me let
me adjust this so I'm no longer
streaming Discord audio.
Aware of 0 to one, usually some
normalization. Yes,
unless there's like a win rate or
whatever.
Any of the M's that are currently going
above one, that is considered a bug that
needs to be fixed.
potentially infinite score in a game.
Yeah.
Just chatted with Finn. I came up with
some interesting and hopefully useful
ideas for how to unblock some of the
progress there. The net hack's already
going very well.
I'm getting it merged in now.
We have lots of ends. There's still a
little bit of testing to do for release.
Uh I didn't stream last night, but I did
mess with the docs a little bit.
I have this so far as the new cheat
sheet.
I did a little bit of work simplifying
the commands.
It's very simple now.
I also updated this.
I still need to update the uh the build
file or the tutorial.
Um
I guess the main question for the
community is like to you guys, what is
the most important stuff that you want
to see done before release?
And if there isn't anything obvious, at
the very least, um, Spencer, we could
also try to figure out any selfplay
changes that need to be made for it.
There are a few M's I definitely want to
see more done with, like this ants end.
Ron's cool for self. We have lots of
cool self plans.
This boss fight en
I'm going to look at the code and see if
this looks vibe coded,
but I think that like some expansion of
this will be nice
potentially. I got to look at converts a
lock and
there were a couple others on here that
I was interested in as well. Craft X
obviously
more clean up for A. I'll get that. Hang
on. Convert.
You don't really want to start
sigmoiding stuff.
I already made that same one locally
convert, but yeah, thanks.
Buffer keeps getting bigger. Yeah, but
funny enough, the code doesn't, right?
I think the code's actually shorter in
this version. Definitely if you're
counting pietorrch it's shorter.
All right, we'll check out Appin lock
since Skinvert is here as soon as I uh
fix my 2FA.
Oh, needs to charge for a minute.
Wait, what the hell?
Oh, this is fine.
That's fine.
That's in vendor. And that's just for
impulse wars.
Deal for Perf.
Can it just be battles one or something?
Battles won versus the uh Is there any
way to win versus the enemy AI?
Hang on. Let me get uh let me make let
me see if my phone works.
It's pretty funny. I have this minimal
phone
and they made a new one that I don't
plan on buying because it looks like
they made it better
and uh I intentionally bought this phone
because it sucks.
It's a pain in the ass to use and as a
result I now spend almost no time on my
phone.
No, it's it's literally a minimal phone.
That's the name.
I wouldn't mind like a better execution
of the same thing.
But I don't really like the direction
that they took the new one
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, there are a few
different ones, but like
it's very funny that like um they say,
"Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. We're not doing
the thing that everyone else is." Yeah.
It's like a minimal thing. Oh, yeah. It
it's minimal. And it has this and this
cuz of course you want that. And it also
has this and this cuz of course you need
that. It's just like the [ __ ]
Like everybody just does the same
goddamn thing that everybody else is
doing and pretends to be doing something
different.
Hey Kvert, what's the score supposed to
be
score perf? I don't know. Let's see. It
says that score is It says that they're
the same.
Okay,
we'll play with That
Well, when you say it's nearly
impossible, like it has to at least be
well defined and stuff, right?
Like Soabon is an instance where the
upper bound is nutty.
All right. I will see. Uh I'll see with
this end then.
AMD support.
Yeah, it's not worth it unfortunately.
It's kind of the same thing as metal
where it's like we could do it but it's
not worth maintaining that.
You can rent a 10-centent per hour
Nvidia GPU on Vast.
If AMD decides to be the one that's
actually shipping like good GPUs for
this application that are affordable and
not be a total mess, then maybe. But
Cuda is also just really good.
Guda is really good.
else look scuffed?
Do the sweeps PRs for battle and drone?
That would be very nice. Note that
battle might actually need some real
work. Like it's possible that some of
the plane models are messed up and stuff
like the physics models.
I don't think it's anything too too
difficult.
1.1 I can add MG you can actually do
that but that doesn't mean that we want
to maintain the code right
so just because you can get something
working quickly with an LLM doesn't mean
that we want it upstreamed
cuz it's like it's a lot to maintain
breakout solves in 5 seconds.
Breakout solves in under 1 second on my
just to make it work locally. You can
totally do that.
If any users want to maintain like an
AMD fork or whatever for the latest
version, I'm fine with people doing
that, but it just doesn't seem worth it
for us to maintain. Note that I did not
just delete like PyTorch with CPU
support and replace it with nothing this
version. We did replace the uh the CPU
thing with something. We replaced it
with very very good CPU evaluation that
does not depend on torch. So now you
should be able to eval uh eval your
model and watch it play on your laptop
regardless of what it has
without needing torch or any [ __ ]
Oh, hey Kvert. You changed. Is it 0.06
with the new metric change that you
introduced?
Because
according to this, it looks like it got
reweed.
before it was higher PF. Is this a long
run though or is this like the 60-cond
config that we have?
Do you have config params for me? Do you
have like a decent like two minute
config or like a decent quick config
that you can paste me real quick?
Just drop it in Discord wherever.
Up time in constellation is in seconds.
Yes.
So, just like pick something that looks
decent that's only going to take me a
couple minutes to train.
I just need some sort of non-trivial
policy so I can look at your env how it
works
It does copy from constellation, but
it's fine.
What's the expected score
or perf or whatever?
Ooh,
this is cool.
I have no idea whether this approach in
particular makes any sense, but things
along this line are at least closer in
my mind than humanoids are.
I wouldn't be surprised it just works
out of the box. Jess, we really aren't
doing any like crazy fancy CUDA things.
We're me. We're like doing pretty simple
stuff.
Okay,
whatever. It's just being slow. It's
fine. I'm kind of tired today. Anyways,
we'll uh we'll get the affe. I'm taking
tomorrow, probably most of tomorrow off,
some rest.
We're pretty good on this release. few
M's are broken and such, but
now I kind of want to figure out which
of these M's are worth cleaning up or um
I mean definitely craft axe.
Like it's kind of funny that this is the
policy, but look at it.
Oh, entities are just despawning though.
Look,
it looks like entities just randomly
despawn
and it's exploiting that
H. We have to fix this.
So many of these types of problems.
Yeah, but this thing is very agile. This
is like the typical like RL just has
perfect control stuff that you expect.
That did take a custom encoder.
All right.
exploits and bugs. Yeah, puffer smart.
This is why it's cool, man. Right. It's
like a very different type of narrow
intelligence from what is out There.
very well could be Jess. It's pretty
easy to try out our like our actual
entity encoder though if you want to
see.
Our encoder is pretty good.
Puff steps per second is two.
That flag shouldn't even exist. Damn it.
Also, what is wrong with this thing that
it's so slow all of a sudden?
I think I did fix the uh the eval render
thing, Jess. Yes,
buffer eval.
I need to fix the speed that it's
rendering this specific envat.
I cleaned up the CLI a little bit and we
have locally here. I still have to push
these but we have a new cheat sheet
reference. So it's just build shen
puffer train puffer eval puffer sweep
build CPU
env.
We hear examples
and there's some extra flags.
I was able to win at depth, too. So,
that's what I'm about to figure out,
Kvert, is like how this thing works.
Dude, why is this thing so stupidly
slow? What is this doing?
we just need to have the stupid models
locally.
Action shift left. Hang on. So, how do
you take control of this first?
Okay, so
one, two, three. Okay, cool. So, we
reset with R.
R does not reset.
Okay. So, step zero of two.
So, current and target.
Oh, I see what this is.
Shift left, shift right, invert.
Huh?
Okay.
I think your scoring seems weird because
this is getting depth X.
I would think score would just be like
the number of levels solved and then
Perf would be
like that over uh the max or something.
This is cool though.
Let's see what the OBS are.
So, this is always doable because it's
like it's fully observable and you know
exactly everything.
It's a nice short end now at this point.
What's this?
Wait. Visible targets.bin.
What is this? Is this like a fixed set
of levels or thing.
Can you BFS it though? I would think you
can't BFS it cuz isn't it like a uh
doesn't it get gigantic at depth 16 or
whatever?
in the generator.
Yeah, but can you I'm asking is it fast
enough to even do that in the generator?
Interesting.
Well, here compute.
Let's see what this is.
observe. You only have two channels
here.
Two channels for a state and two
channels for a target.
Hang on.
You have eight,
but there's 16 things.
And then there's one, two, three. There
are four states.
Hang on. Convert. I want to make sure
that this is not hard because the thing
can't see.
This is pathetic. Grock just does not
work.
So
that's useless.
See, this is the annoying thing about
doing stuff with models, right? because
now now the author of this doesn't know
them doesn't know what the [ __ ] is
happening and I can't even like I can't
even use this for explanation.
Um,
the state is here is for bytes.
The target is four bytes.
why would it be the low bit and the high
bit?
I still don't understand what the hell
this is.
Okay. Wait.
So low bite, high bite.
But wait, what OBS is it getting for
Yes.
But I see four states. One like I see
four states.
Or is it two states?
Is it not like What does the red do?
No. Surely there's there four states,
right?
Why is there mis Why does it show
mismatch on the target then?
Oh, okay. That's visually kind of
screwy, dude.
Okay.
That's kind of screwy to have it that
way.
This is obviously not the right way to
do it, but
You can win that one.
Okay, what do I do?
Do I just have to flip the top bite or
something?
Two is shift R.
Well, it doesn't actually show you
because it the resets.
Okay, we'll fix the render speed and
stuff as well, but that's interesting.
Okay, I can do stuff with this end. I
understand enough.
This should not be the template
environment.
This is no longer I love being able to
simplify our docs and it's like, hey,
you should be adding info to the docs.
But basically anything that needs
clarification
I've just removed because
you know the best clarification is no
clarification needed.
It's actually one of the things that
makes me um
this is one of the things that makes me
excited about this release is the amount
of crap I get to delete. Like, oh yeah,
you have to do this thing to make this
work cleanly. I just don't have any of
that anymore. It's just like, nope, it's
simple. It works. There no like, oh,
it's simple if you do this, if you do
that.
I think you need sight.
That's just profiling.
I love that. That's actually like most
of the documentation work if you think
about it, right?
Just kind of do Yes.
Man, I used to fret over the dock so
much, but now it's so much easier.
Just like the lack of crap everywhere.
just I don't need to have a ton of stuff
because there's just not a ton of crap
to document. You know,
we need the 40 blog on here obviously
before uh release.
Nope. You'd still need the - GPU flag. I
thought about it. Or it's actually d-cu
now. Thank you.
I'm still playing around with the final
flags. I know it annoys the crap out of
everybody who's like, you know, used to
the ones from dev, but I do end up
having to like every release reassess
what is the simplest possible set of
flags.
We'll take simplicity over um
you know backwards consistency every
time.
Nope,
man? How the hell does this [ __ ] break?
Okay. Some small things to fix, but
generally
I'm happy with this.
There's a bunch of little usability
things, I'm sure.
Puffer fish to fix constellation.
But I mean, overall, we are pretty
pretty good.
Let me think if there's anything
exciting that we can do for uh
for the rest of today on this
anything that would really help with our
release.
Let me message Spencer to ask if there's
anything on selfplay that he needs.
Happy luck.
Um,
I don't really understand the code, man.
It's a lot of bit logic.
And it's also I don't understand. I
guess it's split into two files because
of the pregen stuff, which I guess is
okay.
I think we mainly are just going to want
to um rerun us rerun a sweep on the
latest 5. See how it scales there.
And then I'm going to need that data for
constellation right before release
on the late like whatever the final
version of the release is.
I basically am just going to need some
time as well to like play with it and
see how that thing scales.
Um,
and it it could very well become I'll
probably market silver as well and then
after a while like this could very well
become one of the most important
benchmarkers
could become a very useful benchmark.
I was looking for a very nice synthetic
env and this is pretty good.
I don't like that it's sort of difficult
to intuit it is the one thing. So it's a
nice synthetic env.
It's a little hard to in it.
I think that's the main limitation.
installation data. It's just all the
experiment.json files, man,
is what it is.
Or what is it? The I don't know if
they're I think they might be any files
now, actually.
All the files
I actually before I do it with this, I
really should um let me check if this
just is a really high quality end code
because I don't want to use this if the
end code is very high quality.
If the end code is like mediumish
quality,
I'm fine.
with doing That
How long is this?
Does still seem long.
Well, if this if this is obviously bad,
I just won't take This
is a thousand subs on that. That's
funny.
We'll see whether that fixes. I would
like to have a new arcade game. Be right
back. Maybe Space Invaders as well,
though. That one's probably easier.
full roll out per frame. I see
that should not happen.
Does it happen? Does it even have to
move?
Rapid shooting mechanic. Well, it just
might not be implemented correctly,
right?
Oh, wait. What the [ __ ] You can just
spam bullets like in the original
Wait, how is this hard if you can just
spam bullets?
Is this how it works? Is this actually
the accurate one?
you do kind of just steamroll it
otherwise.
Hey man,
sleepy.
Asteroids was supposed to be like a
tough end.
Okay, this is at least more interesting
the way it's playing.
Well, the control is also very
difficult. Hold.
Wait, what if you go across? What
happens?
Yeah, our bullet lifetime is way too
screwy.
Oh, and they just snipe you, huh?
That's funny.
That's a good little project for
somebody to figure out. I suppose
I'm fine with that for now. There's not
like a really obvious trivial way to
make this
uh to make this one work cuz the
original game is screwy.
That's fine.
is Space Invaders actually hard for an
AI
like this policy is oh it can't see
bullets
Space Invaders have levels
and surely this one is
just insta solved right with correct
setup. up.
He leaves like craft decks and stuff for
the most part.
I think I'm kind of fine with that for
now.
Yeah, this these are alone are good I
think.
I do have a little bit of time.
I'm trying to think is there anything
else major we can clean up or improve
All right. I mean, we do have lots of
little things to fix. It seems still on
the ends.
We can fix double pendulum at least.
Yeah. Idiot thing.
This is not the reward that I I never
specified this reward in any way.
You see it's way harder now.
Mhm.
What am I up to? Playing with a couple
of the M's that are kind of broken
That actually should not give it good
reward though, should it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. There's something
wrong here.
Max,
why would you make it zero?
That's hilarious. Look, it just
introduced this.
This is how you can tell these models
are so dumb.
I mean, I did literally tell them the
reward function to use.
It wasn't working cuz the reward was
[ __ ] stupid.
We'll see if this does it.
It probably will need a retune.
This is not handholdy reward shaping.
This is just the environment being set
up. Stupid.
The reward I have is literally just
delta height.
It's really shitty and inefficient.
Um, you can't really do anything
meaningful without a stupid amount of
money in compute. And then even then
you're kind of just stuck to running
really dumb algorithms on as much data
as you can scrape.
It's definitely possible to overengineer
your rewards.
Probably reward farm from end of
episode.
Well, I guess it might know the uh the
timeout, huh?
This is me trying to do something with
it, which I obviously can't.
and it just spins like crazy obviously
once you lose control of it.
Controls are very floaty as well. I have
no idea whether this version is even
solvable, right?
Well, I really don't have the uh energy
to be doing this at the moment.
I think having like an end pendulum
version would be fun though.
I suspect this particular env is not not
set up correctly. Yeah, you can look
into it crit. Um,
you got it to work. Yeah, by all means
then.
I definitely need to think about our
template end. I can do that for a
second. Hang on.
No,
I think that's it, guys. I got time, but
I'm just out of juice today.
I kind of did a whole bunch of stuff
over the weekend
um on dev and I'm sort of just out of
juice.
Do we have our build stable?
Oh, that's at least one thing that we
should look at, right?
Let's at least make sure that we have
the um the eval render thing stable.
Yeah, we don't have the frame skip loop
in, but other than that, this is fine.
I'm happy.
I think I call it there.
I think I uh I call it there for the
day. Thanks for tuning in, folks. I
think I'm probably going to take
tomorrow off because I didn't take any
time off this weekend. Um
recuperate, get some exercise in and the
like. And then we'll spend the rest of
this week polishing up release, testing
anything that needs testing,
maybe writing some of the articles. I'll
start thinking about that a little bit
as well
and yeah we will go from there.